we just come off the back of a really
moving interview I know that you guys
are both very moved by it as well and
and we were sort of talking about how it
is important isn't to sort of humanize
politicians as well and
absolutely and I think it's it's that
thing it's kind of understanding that
our politicians are people who sometimes
go through horrible forms of grief as
well I think it's sometimes a useful
reminder given all the abuse they get
and you know the rightful scrutiny and
accountability which can be really
robust I think it's sometimes good to
remember their people too but also there
is such a terrible stigma still around
um miscarriage and it's a very kind of
particular painful form of grief I think
uh that that we we're starting to get
better as a society at talking about um
but I think there's probably still some
way to go yet yeah and I do think that
it's wonderful that guys talking about
it because it can't be easy at all but
you know that interview is going to
prompt conversations that interview
might sort of help somebody going
through a similar experience or help
other people understand whether those
experiences are so I think uh a really
great interview to do yeah I was really
happy that he was come to enough to
share his story and he did like you say
you could tell you can tell by the way
he was in the interview how impacted he
clearly he still felt by it and also I
guess you know this is what Westminster
is best isn't it when you have people
who've gone through something like that
life-changing you'll never get over it
as he says you know you just learn to
live with it rather than moving on from
there yeah and you can use your
experience to think hang on this like
why don't we have better leave for
example for people who've gone through
losing a child for a baby it should
happen you know and actually use their
position to to make a change no
absolutely and quite often on these
sorts of issues it goes cross-party as
well which I think is a useful reminder
that you know despite our politics which
can be very toxic at times there are
some issues actually which politicians
from different values and different
political Traditions can find Common
Ground yeah yeah really difficult
subject to talk about I know like you
know we're all getting you know it's
difficult stuff so you know
um we can talk a little bit more about
some of the other stories that we
covered on the program uh today the big
sort of announcement this morning was
about child sexual exploitation
and to try and get a basically a duty
for people to report if they've got any
concerns about particular children
because we've seen very vulnerable kids
in particular being targeted right
absolutely and it is really important so
we had the independent inquiry on child
sexual abuse which reported last year
after many many years of work I think
it's important to say look to all forms
of child sexual abuse in society so in
institutions grooming gangs but also in
the home and actually the sort of child
sexual abuse that goes on in the home it
is more common than we'd like to think
and it's really to boot all forms of
child sexual abuse are very taboo and
that gets in the way of it being
reported dealt with
so much of it is preventable but we sort
of leave children to suffer so I think
it's really good to see that the Home
Secretary is taking one of the
recommendations of that independent
inquiry last year my concern about this
announcement which is basically putting
a legal Duty on professionals who work
with children to report suspicions of
child sexual abuse
my concern about it is it puts a lot of
emphasis on the law as an instrument of
change and makes it sound like you know
this stuff isn't getting reported
because you know they're not legally
obliged to do it whereas actually if you
look at the research on this we know
that um you know it's very very taboo in
society which means that social workers
teachers Etc they can be quite reluctant
to identify it as a form of suspected
abuse because they know what it might
mean for a family in a school and I
guess I'd get it wrong then absolutely
there's not there's not enough training
around it for you know even social
workers get quite limited training on
child selection abuse what the signs to
watch for so the idea that you can just
fix it with a change in the law is I
think wrong and I think we've got so
much to do as a society to think about
well how do we keep you know how do
child professionals working with
children really keep their eyes and ears
peeled for some of the signs of child's
attributes because it is preventable you
know there are signs and children can be
taken out of those situations
unsupported but too many children are
being left to suffer this awful crime
alone I do think that the interesting
thing here is that you can put something
down as a statute and a duty but
ultimately are you going to be able to
pull the system together in terms of
resourcing and you know these cultural
issues and training that you've just
mentioned Sonia about you need to get
what you want as the outcome so I mean
it's all it's all that stuff that we're
so used to in Westminster is that the
announcement is there you know that the
press release has gone out but actually
the follow-through is going to require
years of effort to make this actually
work yeah because it is so difficult
like you say and actually it's
interesting because you know I'm always
one of these people who I think if we're
talking about crimes that are
predominantly impacting women and girls
we should call that out and say it is
but I was quite pleased actually was
like actually there's a lot of boys that
yeah this impacts as well yeah and this
can be even more taboo and more
difficult yeah maybe not but but you
know it can be very difficult for them
yeah it's it's so to be it's so
different difficult for children to talk
about and raise their hands and say that
something's happening to them which is
why it's so important that every one who
works for children is aware of some of
the signs of it and feels comfortable
reporting it investigating it but we
definitely have a child protection
system at the moment where it is to
Taboo yeah even amongst professionals
working with children so you know that's
that's why we're not able to do what we
should be doing for these children you
spoke a bit about
um in Westminster where you get the
press release out but it's the follow
through that matters and I just think
this really applies to some of the
policies around immigration as well
because with the interview today you
know I was trying to there's so much you
can ask the Home Secretary about right
so you're kind of like thinking okay can
do this this police the announcement
today you've got immigration how do you
Whittle down and I could have made the
decision I guess not to focus too much
on Rwanda because it hasn't happened
right like no one's been sent there and
I do still have a bit of skepticism
about whether it is going to happen at
all because of the delays I don't know
what you sort of will sort of focus on
it well I think that there's so much
that is going on behind the scenes so as
a former home office special advisor you
know my sympathy
with you know the difficulty of what you
need to do and the home secretary's
remit is so broad you know at any given
moment she's probably got sort of eight
crises going on that we're not even
aware of
um so you know I have some sympathy for
that what I think is interesting is that
you go big so you know like the prime
minister at the beginning of the year
has said we're going to deal with the
small boat stuff
um but then actually following through
with that then becomes difficult because
there are challenges that will come your
way that you probably didn't expect or
the ones that you did expect or you know
whatever you know tone that takes is
challenging so I do think that there is
a limit to what you can actually say as
kind of you know a running narrative
before you actually get to a point where
either something is fixed or it's really
obvious that it's not going to be she
said be judging the record and she will
be right yeah I mean she's really
holding herself hostage and Fortune
there because I mean I I agree with you
Sophie I think it's a completely
unworkable plan experts oblit it there
are so many holes in it whether it's
kind of international law whether it's
the practicalities of where do you
detain people arriving in the UK I mean
there's detention is much much more
expensive than housing Asylum Seekers
we've got nowhere to do that you know
Rwanda the agreement with Rwanda is to
take you know what is effectively a
small handful of of you know the people
who are arriving on on small boats
um where are the where are the vests
going to go I mean it's just totally not
worked out and I can't help think that
if you're a home secretary that was
genuinely interested in addressing the
issue around an increasing volume of
Asylum claims but it's not the highest
it's ever been at the moment it is high
but it's not the highest it's ever been
lots of countries are seeing an increase
what you would do is focus on making the
Asylum system more Humane but also more
more robust so you would process lots of
people are genuine Asylum Seekers who
are fleeing terrible conflict you know
from regions like Afghanistan where
Britain has been involved
um you know you would Pro you would look
at their claims you would assess them
fairly and quickly so people who've got
a logistics intimate claim to be here
can get a job can work for example can
start a new life but people who don't
have a legitimate claim you you Deport
and you deal with that at the moment
people who are genuine asylums because
people who suffered the most awful kinds
of torture and human rights abuses are
trapped in a system where it takes
months even years to process our
application that's not Humane it's not
fair to them and it's not fair in terms
of the system in terms you know there
are people here who could be deported I
are slightly In Contention though I
think if you're looking at from her
perspective and I'm playing devil's
advocate here I think the issue is how
many of the people that are coming over
via this route small boats route are
genuine Asylum Seekers now I don't I'm
not saying one way or another but I
think there has to be better numbers
that are published because the
contention from the home office is that
actually you're getting a lot of people
who are coming over that are economic
migrants and I think there should be
much better numbers yeah but if you look
at the countries from which they're
coming
um you know the the top five countries
in terms of Asylum claims or countries
where we you know we know that there's a
very high success rate although Albania
is top where in terms of small boat
arrivals not in terms of the general
Albania I think is top of small boat
yeah yes exactly small boat but in
general
if you look at the overall Asylum system
the top five countries which include
small boats right but you're right
there's a different statistic
um but even with Albania so so there's a
lot of claims made that this is you know
these are the only way you can figure
this out is by process processing yeah
and getting better data there are
genuine because we have a massive human
trafficking problem across Europe that
actually affects women and girls women
being you know traffic for for sex work
essentially uh prostitution so um you
know it's it's I think it suits the Home
Secretary to be able to make claims
without evidence without even validity
of when it's out of time it is such a
hot issue we could be talking about it
all morning thank you so much for uh
coming on the program today great to
talk to you I heard both on the show
today